sulfurous fumes fill the air in this
region just west of Cologne lignite or
brown coal is being burned to generate
electricity and the people working at
this power plant hope it won't stop
anytime soon don't cause I hope to see
brown coal used here for another 45 or
50 years we won't go down my job is here
to stay Germany's transition to
renewable energy like wind and solar
power doesn't appear to have included
the state of North rhine-westphalia
brown coal is still the dominant energy
source despite having the highest carbon
emissions environmentalists dip yawns
and thinks politicians aren't doing
enough for climate protection a line yet
the year alone the for brown coal power
plants belonging to energy corporation
rwe expel 85 million tons of co2 every
year that's around ten percent of the
whole of Germany's carbon emissions so
they determine whether or not climate
protection targets are met North
rhine-westphalia fails Germany fails and
of course that's a fatal signal with
regard to the Paris Climate Change
Conference big of debate kima confidence
environmentalists have been campaigning
against lignite mining for decades and
this year more than ever before
yeah I'm in my place in April we held
the biggest demonstration ever in
Rhineland 6,000 people formed a human
chain their message was stop strip
mining stop it right here right now it's
archaic technology and it's just not
necessary anymore energy giant rwe has
been relying on coal for too long now
and its business model is in decay the
old coal-fired power plants are
lucrative but they're harming the
environment step by step they'll be
forced to shut down new revenue sources
will be hard to find because rwe hasn't
invested enough in renewable
technologies but the rhine lands open
pit mines still have enough coal
reserves to last 30 more years and rwe
wants to exploit those reserves as a son
finish or needs info ah step on cause
it's not sensible or helpful to panic
and abandon lignite prematurely we
needed as a backup for renewable energy
and to ensure Germany's power supply
well not it also keeps prices affordable
at al-assad aim they haven't afar of
them there would be fatal consequences
for the people who live here in this
region of Germany if we suddenly stopped
using brown coal overnight I'll call it
to look upon good
he gets in hug amid the dispute about
Cole the group can at least rely on
support from the union because 10,000
jobs are at risk give India freedom
we're in favor of brown coal we have a
common interest in defending these jobs
what brown coal isn't just mind here to
provide work Cole also keeps prices in
Germany competitive and guarantees a
supply of electricity yet these are all
important factors alongside employment
and they shouldn't be overlooked you
need up on tony ferguson those in favor
of brown coal say it's the cheapest
energy source and the costs of making
the mining areas in habitable again are
unclear anyway excavators are set to
chew their way through the Rhineland for
the next 30 years even if that means
destroying ancient villages like Emma
hot a thousand people once called this
home now it's derelict Jensen's family
was also forced out to make way for a
strip mine now there's nothing left but
ruins what's right our expropriation was
declared unconstitutional the facts were
there but it was too late our property
was already in a hole 200 metres deep
with a so far none of the people
displaced by strip mining in Germany
have had a chance to defend themselves
in core in time so that's it all the
houses in mo hot as well as its church
are to be demolished the little village
is sitting on a lick night deposit
mining is planned to continue until 2045